I work at the front desk of a private
company I have two sons one works and
the other goes to college
the vegetables I used to buy for 12
cents now cost more than double earlier
the cost of five kilograms of flour was
one dollar and now it costs two dollars
the price of a gas cylinder is now
thirteen dollars every item in the house
has become more expensive
I pay more to travel to the office on
the Metro earlier it cost me 12 cent but
now it costs over 20 cents the price of
traveling in an auto rickshaw has also
gone up when the kids were younger I
spent less on their school fees but now
they're growing so are their costs it is
difficult to meet their expenses now I
have to pay more for their clothes
school fees and tuition fees
keeping up with monthly medical bills
has become very hard doctors are now
charging at least six dollars for a
consultation earlier they charged less
even medicine costs a lot more now
everyone in India is having a hard time
because of inflation and Rising prices
and things which are Basic Essentials
are very expensive now the government
can prevent prices from going up prices
for basic needs like flour milk and the
school bus fees should be kept in check
if the government lowers the prices for
some of these Necessities it will help
better manage our monthly bills